what does desperation look like well if
you're michigan governor gretchen
witless whitmer it means spending
millions to target a republican who
hasn't even won her primary yet
put michigan first as a group aligned
with whitmer and the democratic
governors association it's spending at
least two million bucks on this last
minute attack ad against the republican
tudor dixon
tudor dixon's dangerous budget plan
could slash up to 500 million from state
police across michigan the michigan
association of police organizations says
dixon's approach would have a
devastating impact on police budgets
leaving law enforcement crippled tudor
dixon's devastating plan would mean less
cops on the street
making michigan less safe
fewer cops not less cops but grammar
aside whitmer is attempting to paper
over her own positions here she was back
in 2020.
you look at budgets and they are
overwhelmingly focused on policing and
correction systems and the criminal
justice system do you think that the
defunding would you be someone who
supports the defunding movement i think
you do all those other things you don't
need all the money that's going in the
police department so yeah i mean the
spirit of it i i do support that spirit
of it
joining me is tudor dixon gop
gubernatorial candidate who's leading in
the primary in michigan uh tudor great
to see you tonight is it possible that
whitmer
has suddenly had a change of heart on
the defund the police movement
absolutely not but she's a great
gaslighter i mean right now she's also
telling us that she increased auto jobs
in the state and that's a complete lie
they're trying to attack me because
they're scared of me she knows i'm
leading in the polls but i find this
really interesting in the state of
michigan because the democratic
governors association hasn't gotten
involved in any republican races yet so
far this cycle except for ours and this
is a very pointed attack to have more
than two million dollars go into an ad
in the last seven days of the primary
just to get me out of there she's
definitely afraid they're afraid they
already see that she's the most
vulnerable governor in america and yet
they're still pitching her to be
president of the united states in 2024
they don't want her to get kicked out
and they know i can do it
well i i i've never heard of this
scenario before where an incumbent
governor
and her allied organizations are
spending two million dollars against
another candidate who hasn't won the
primary yet it's very odd they're
obviously totally threatened by a smart
you know attractive woman with a you
know corporate background in the steel
industry uh to run against her but
michigan live is reporting that about 56
percent of the 9.5 whitmer raised from
individuals is
from michiganders roughly 24
300 donors but it also got money from
nearly 31
600 donors from outside the state
and i'm not just talking about donors
who might be outside of the state lines
take a look at this map
they're from all over the country tudor
they are really worried about their
lockdown
lover
gretchen whitmer going down in flames
here and i think they're most worried
about you
of course she has a terrible record
we're coming out with a message that
really resonates with the people of
michigan we want to bring back our
education system that's been in decline
for many years we want safe cities
that's the best part i'm out here
constantly talking about putting more
money into policing making sure our
cities are safe and incentivizing police
officers to come to the state of
michigan because we need them
desperately and becoming investment
friendly to our job creators these are
all things that she has a terrible
record on you played her saying that she
supports the spirit of defund the police
that she would love to see that money
out of the budget spent in different
ways she's using her own attack against
us it's it's very comical it's very
flattering but i need help
tudor um we need a conservative female
governor and one of our battleground
states and you would be it so tudor
dixon tuesday is the primary right
yes absolutely go vote
all right everybody get out and vote on
tuesday in michigan tudor dixon thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else